Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan. Wir stehen wieder vor dem Salon und haben heute viel vor.
Du hast mir gestern via Twitter schon geschrieben, so viele Notizen habe ich
mir noch nie zuvor gemacht für einen Salon. Woran liegt das?
Ich habe es mir gerade ausgedruckt. Es sind sechs Seiten, also für alle 100
Seiten habe ich mir ungefähr ein doppelseitiges, es sind 874 Seiten oder so gewesen.
Ah, dann hast du eine andere, du hast das online digital gelesen,
bei mir sind das 600 Seiten, aber sehr eng bedruckt und große Seiten.
Genau, es passt nämlich nicht zusammen. Ich habe mir die Leseprobenansicht des
Druckexemplars aufgerufen, um zu sehen, in welchem Text bin ich denn eigentlich
gerade? In der E-Version und dann passte das gar nicht zusammen.
Also liegen echt 200 Seiten dazwischen. Also in der E-Version sind es 874 Seiten.
Wovon sprechen wir? Wir sprechen von dem Buch Chinesisches Denken der Gegenwart
Schlüsseltexte zu Politik und Gesellschaft übersetzt und kommentiert von Daniel
Lese und Xi Ming erschienen bei CH Beck.
Und dieses Buch ist ein wichtiges Buch, denn es gewährt uns einen Einblick in
das, was in den Köpfen der intellektuellen Eliten vor sich geht in China.
Es sind Personen dabei, die das Regime von Xi kritisch sehen.
Es sind aber auch viele Autoren darunter, die Xi rechtfertigen,
die sagen, alles geht genau seinen richtigen Weg und so war es immer auch schon gedacht.
Und das sind eigentlich die interessantesten Texte. Also die Kritik können wir ja selbst liefern.
Da wird es aufschlussreich, wo diese Leute einfach mal so ins Reden kommen und
erzählen, wie sie sich zum Beispiel auch ein digitales China vorstellen.
Also ich würde ohnehin sagen, so kritisch im Sinne von westlich kritisch,
wie man halt auf China blickt, ist wirklich nur der einundzwanzigste,
also der allerletzte Text.
Alle anderen zwanzig gehen so auf verschiedene Richtungen und zeigen auch mal,
darüber reden wir dann, eine Denktiefe oder nicht und woher das so rührt.
Ich bin sehr beeindruckt davon und freue mich sehr auf die Diskussion,
denn ich habe viele Fragen auch an dich und auch, wir müssen vielleicht nochmal
über die eine oder andere Debatte, Überwachungskapitalismus.
Muss man vielleicht auch nochmal anders sehen.
Jedenfalls gibt es auch sehr eigenartige Interpretationen von westlichen Texten
in diesen chinesischen Texten. Man ist doch verblüfft, wie das woanders rezipiert wird.
Aber es ist auch nicht schlecht, dass wir als letztes großes Buch Anfänger hatten
von Grabber, wo ja auch so ein Kulturtransport usw. thematisiert wurde. Und hier jetzt wieder.
Nicht ganz so deutlich wie in, also explizit titelgebend.
Aber das fand ich gut, dass wir Anfänge noch im Hinterkopf haben,
um jetzt dieses Ding zu lesen.
Was hast du noch mitgebracht?
Des Weiteren lesen wir ...
Ein Text in der Süddeutschen Zeitung über die Leute, die Christian Lindner Geld
auf das Staatsschuldentilgungskonto überweisen.
Man ist dem mal nachgegangen, man nennt den Text auch eine Fahndung,
denn ich halte das ehrlich gesagt auch für ein privates Verbrechen, was da stattfindet.
Also in der Hinsicht wird da mal nachgeschaut, wer denn so irre ist.
Adam Tooze wendet sich in einem kurzen aber prägnanten Text gegen das 2% Inflationsziel
in allen westlichen Regionen.
Und ich dachte mir, ja das lesen wir heute mal, weil wir haben letzten Monat
in Amerika den eigentlichen,
auch erstmal nur in Anführungszeichen vorläufigen Abschied von der Schuldenobergrenze
und in Deutschland kleben wir, ja nicht nur in Deutschland, Lindner zwingt es
ja allen auf, die Schuldenbremse.
Und deswegen gehen wir hier mal in diese vielleicht noch sogar wichtigere Diskussion kurz.
Dann hat Evgenij Morozov in der New York Times eine große Abhandlung über die
eigentliche Bedrohung von Künstlicher Intelligenz geschrieben.
Und sie kommt deiner Kritik sehr nah.
Das freut mich besonders.
Und wir gehen das nochmal durch, denn ich finde das auch ganz wichtig,
was er schreibt. Und als letztes meinerseits gibt es Neues aus der Küchenpsychologie.
Ich habe hier schon so ein Buch rumliegen, das heißt Mood Food,
also das Essen nicht nur für den Körper, sondern auch für den Geist gut ist.
Und neue Erkenntnisse legen wohl nahe, dass man 30 Prozent der Depressionen
damit einfangen könnte, indem man einfach anders isst.
Also während wir für den Körper ja die Makronährstoffe und so weiter,
geht es da jetzt in die tausenden Mikrobiomen oder wie sie auch immer heißen.
Heißen und was ich auch nicht wusste aber in unserem Darm alleine leben 20 Billionen
Mikro-irgendwas und dann steht im Text das ist mehr als wir Zellen haben im Körper.
Also es ist wirklich crazy was da vor sich geht.
Ich möchte mich dem Thema, brauchen wir einen linken Populismus annehmen,
das ist etwas, was wir immer wieder thematisiert haben und auch bejahen, wer bejaht das noch?
Natürlich Chantal Mouffe, sie ist die Politologin, die diesen Populismus-Gedanken stark macht,
die sagt, nein, Populismus kann auch sehr progressiv sein und sie hat ein neues
Buch bei Surkamp veröffentlicht, wo sie auch versucht, die Ökologie mit einem
linken Populismus zu verbinden.
Ich würde mich aber auch über das Buch hinausgehend zu MUFF äußern und da einige Anmerkungen zu machen.
Dann habe ich einen wunderschönen Roman gelesen, Der Tanzende,
von Victor Jastin, von einem jungen Mann, der erst mit dem Club fremdelt,
dann aber doch immer mal wieder dorthin geht und plötzlich bleibt.
Und er tanzt jede Nacht dort und das wird sein Lebensinhalt, eine Welt, die mir sehr,
persönlich sehr fern ist, aber in diesem Roman wurde es mir völlig plausibel.
Dann sprechen wir über...
Also Techno-Club und so, es geht so richtig ins...
Ja, es ist eine, früher hatte man wohl gesagt Disco, also es ist nicht so ein
ganz, es ist ein bisschen in der Provinz.
Und es ist jetzt auch nicht die Dorf-Disco, aber es ist jetzt eher so,
dass die Großraum-Disco, hätte man früher gesagt, wo alles Mögliche kommt,
von Rihanna bis Ariana Grande.
Aber man kann dort eigentlich sein Leben verbringen. Dann habe ich einen sensationellen
Text aus dem Freitag zum Thema, wieso müssen Männer kämpfen?
Warum werden eigentlich Männer in den Krieg geschickt? Und warum wird das auch
gerade gar nicht kritisiert?
Aber geht es über Krieg hinaus?
Ja, ich finde, dass dieser Text über einiges hinausgeht. Es geht jetzt nicht
darum zu sagen, wie ist das Rekrutierungsverhalten in der Ukraine,
sondern was ist das generell für einen Blick, auf Männer, die kämpfen müssen
und zu Soldaten werden und sind sie dann eigentlich noch Menschen?
Und wie betrauen wir sie? Also Elsa Köster hat da wirklich einen herausragenden Text geschrieben.
Und dann schauen wir noch nach Indien, auf die Ungleichheit in der indischen Tribune.
War da ein erstaunlicher Text. Und es gibt ein Interview mit Yannis Varoufakis bei Zeit Online.
Nathaniel Hefner hat es geführt und es geht um den digitalen Euro und warum
der eine große Chance sein kann.
Aber bevor wir jetzt in den Salon schreiten, wollen wir...
Du hast durchs Fernsehen geguckt.
Ich habe, nein, ich habe natürlich kein Fernsehen geguckt, sondern ich habe
Twitter geguckt und dort ist mir ein Clip aufgefallen.
Und zwar, es geht um die Zukunft der CDU, die uns ja alle so interessiert.
Nein, wir sehen dort Jens Spahn sitzen und im Hintergrund ist eingeblendet,
der Auftritt von Pechstein, die diese Rede hielt,
die Kinder sollen Mama und Papa sagen müssen und ich will wieder Zigeunerschnitzel
sagen und da steht sie da mit Polizeiuniform und Markus Lanz will jetzt Spahn etwas fragen,
aber eigentlich fragt er ihn gar nicht, sondern erhält einfach mal eine kurze
Rede und ich finde diese Ansprache an sich sehr schön.
Ich fand es amüsant, dass bei Twitter, Nicole Diekmann gleich sagt,
ja aber so sei ja auch nicht, so könne man ja nicht reden, also man muss ja
mal miteinander sprechen.
Also das ist immer noch diese Idee, wir müssen mal in den Dialog treten.
Vielleicht kann man auch gar nicht mehr in den Dialog treten,
Vielleicht muss man so sprechen.
Steht dann da oben und sagt einfach mal entspannt Zigeuner-Schnitzel.
Warum? Und will Gespenster vertreiben, die außer Ihnen keiner sieht.
Ja, aber das müssen ja auch ... Und Merz findet's brillant. Also,
Herr Land ... Hat dieses Land keine anderen Probleme, außer elende Gendersternchen,
Zigeunerschnitzel, Radwege in Berlin, all diese Themen?
Öffentlich-rechtliche Verkehrsmittel, das böse öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen,
gegenderte, heute kam's wieder, gegenderte Nachrichtensendungen.
Sollen wir uns mal eins festhalten? Ihr Parteivorsitzender, das ist mir vor
einigen Wochen aufgefallen, wie jeder gegenderte Nachrichtensatz in einem öffentlich-rechtlichen
Fernsehsender führt dazu, dass wieder hunderte Stimmen rübergehen zur AfD. Ganz kurz.
Weder in der Tagesschau, noch in der Heute, noch im Heute-Journal,
noch in den Tagesthemen, noch hier gendert irgendjemand.
Aber Herr Lanz. Das ist genau das, was ich meine. Das ist genau die Sache mit
die Grünen wollen euch das Haus verbieten von einer Frau, deren Namen sie noch nicht markiert haben.
Ja, sehr schön. Jens Spahn möchte natürlich jetzt so ganz ruhig antworten,
aber er lässt ihn einfach nicht. Und ich finde, das ist eine gute Art und Weise,
wie man mit Jens Spahn sprechen sollte.
Wenn Jens Spahn Janina Spahn wäre, wäre das gleich wieder Mansplaining und dann
gäbe es eine andere Twitter-Diskussion.
Aber man kann ja Lanz Radikalisierung nachvollziehen, wenn man einfach den Podcast,
den er mit Precht macht, hört, der ja sehr gut ist.
Und die sitzen ja dann eine Stunde zusammen und tanken sich so richtig voll,
dass es für eine Woche reicht, in denen man sich auch, also schon die ganze
Zeit immer fragte, aber wenn du in deinem Podcast so darüber redest,
warum machst du dann trotzdem so eine Quatsch Sendung?
Und jetzt so langsam schwappt das Podcast Gefühl bei ihm so in seine Sendung.
Sehr schön. Aber diese Frage stellt sich ja, warum treibt die CDU diesen Kulturkampf auf die Spitze?
Warum ist der Kulturkampf überhaupt so wichtig? Und tatsächlich,
glaube ich ja schon, wird dieser Kulturkampf Menschen ansprechen,
die wählen dann nicht die CDU, sondern wir hatten es im letzten Podcast schon
gesagt, die wählen dann das Original, die wählen die AfD.
Aber man könnte ja auch fragen, ja, es gibt diesen einen Kulturkampf jetzt von
rechts. Zum anderen gibt es natürlich auch einen enger werdenden Meinungskorridor.
Und es gibt jetzt Menschen, die...
Sich in irgendeiner Weise davon angesprochen fühlen, hier mit uns könnt ihr
es noch machen. Also ich will euch nicht gängeln.
Das sagte ja auch Armin Laschet bei dem TRIEL. Er sagte, ich will niemanden
gängeln. Also wir wollen die Leute lassen.
Und das ist ja erstmal eine Frage, die man sich so stellen kann.
Und diese Frage stellte sich auch Nils Schniederjahn im Deutschlandfunk.
Der hatte Thomas Biebricher zu Gast, der ja sehr viel über Neoliberalismus und
Konservatismus geschrieben hat.
Und der sehr gut aufzeigen kann, wie die Konservativen sich eigentlich entkernt haben.
Ich empfehle das Interview sehr. Wir hören uns aber jetzt nicht die Antworten
von Biebrich an, sondern nur mal zwei Fragen von Schnieder Jan und versuchen
die auch mal zu beantworten oder sehen da auch schon eine Antwort in der Fragestellung.
Was mich besonders fasziniert hat, als ich über die Zeit von Kohls geistig-moralischer
Wende bei ihm gelesen habe, war eben, dass er doch mit einem sehr,
sehr anderen Anspruch, glaube ich, an die Bürger herangetreten ist,
als wir das heute erleben.
Also, dass dieses Sprechen von einer geistig-moralischen Wende und geistig-moralischen
Krise impliziert ja schon, dass die Menschen sich auch verändern sollen.
Man tritt sozusagen mit einem hohen Anspruch an die Bürger.
Und ich frage mich, hat sich da nicht die Art und Weise, wie eine konservative
Partei an die Bürger herantritt, ganz deutlich geändert?
Weil mein Eindruck ist, heute ist die Ansprechhaltung eigentlich eine,
die ein Entlastungsversprechen mit sich bringt.
Zu sagen, egal was du machst, ob du jetzt dein Schnitzel isst,
ob du jetzt irgendwelche Lieder singst, ob du noch eine Gasheizung im Keller
hast, wie du es machst, ist das alles schon gut.
Ist diese Entlastungshaltung, mit der man rangeht, wie kam es zu der?
Würden sie dem zustimmen?
Und was macht die vielleicht dann auch mit so einem politischen Diskurs?
Sehr gute Frage, die natürlich nicht an uns gerichtet ist, aber wir können sie trotzdem beantworten.
Meine Antwort ist, als die Grünen anfingen,
über 20 Prozent zu liegen in den letzten Zügen von Merkels Amtszeit,
hat Lars Klingbeil und Scholz sich den Plan gestellt, wir machen das grüne Versprechen,
aber sagen den Leuten, das geht auch ohne Anstrengung.
Also wir nehmen diese ganzen grünen Sachen ernst, aber das geht auch so,
dass man die Leute in Ruhe lässt.
Und dieses Versprechen konnte ja Scholz nie einlösen. Er ist ja dann nur durch
Glück und nicht durch solche bescheuerten Ideen ins Amt gekommen.
Und Lars Klingbeil denkt aber,
das war der Pfad, der die SPD an die Macht führte. Also blieben sie dabei.
Dass Scholz ganz zurückgelehnt die Grünen einfach sozusagen voranstürmen ließ.
Und dann immer versuchte so im Nachhinein, wie er jetzt auch wieder,
sich einzuschalten, um nochmal die soziale Seite zu betonen,
also dass die Kindergrundsicherung muss kommen oder wie auch immer.
Und damit, Lisa, diese Herangehensweise.
Nach der konservativen Regierung kommt eine sozialdemokratische,
die uns verspricht, ja, wir machen Klimawandel, aber ganz bequem.
Das hat, glaube ich, Bernd Ullrich auch mal so beschrieben, in einem Text nur zu diesem Thema.
Und dann kam die CDU und meinte, na, wir wollen die ja auch nicht überfordern.
Wenn Scholz von denen nichts fordert, können wir von denen auch nichts fordern.
Und dann schwenkten alle auf diese Dagegenhaltung ein. Wir haben ja beim letzten
Mal gesagt, die CDU versucht das was zu machen, was die AfD macht,
also drum zu kritisieren.
Und der Ursprung dafür, dass die CDU sich auch nichts anderes traut,
ist eigentlich, glaube ich, diese SPD-Liturgie, die da schon im Wahlkampf drin steckte.
Möglicherweise liegt es aber auch daran, dass die CDU inzwischen natürlich sehr
davon profitiert oder schon immer sehr davon profitiert hat,
dass viele Menschen ein Umfeld haben, eine Lebenswelt haben,
die sie als unpolitisch wahrnehmen.
Wenn ihre Löhne nicht steigen, wenn die Straßen nicht gebaut werden,
wenn die Züge nicht fahren, dann nehmen das viele Menschen nicht wahr,
in dem Sinne als, das adressiere ich an jene oder diese Partei.
Zwar würden sie immer sagen, die Politik macht da irgendwie nichts,
oder es läuft so wenig, Sie sehen es oft nicht als ein politisches an und gerade
bei Löhnen oder bei Kinderbetreuung,
bei all diesen Fragen, ist das eine private Angelegenheit oder ist es eine Frage,
die man mit mehr Geld besser lösen kann?
Aber das ist erstmal der unpolitische Raum, der imaginiert wird.
Und in diesen unpolitischen Raum kommt jetzt so eine Forderung wie Heizungen
müssen ausgebaut werden oder demnächst nicht mehr diese alten eingebaut werden und, und, und.
Und damit wird also plötzlich dieser Raum politisiert, weil das ja politische
Maßnahmen sind, die viele Leute, die also zur ...
Die in der sogenannten Mittelschicht gehören, sonst nicht gespürt haben.
Jemand, der Hartz-IV-Empfang hat, hat den Staat jeden Monat gespürt in aller Deutlichkeit.
Wenn man ein gewisses Gehalt hat, muss man zwar Steuern zahlen und man ärgert
sich über das eine oder andere, aber man spürt den Staat nicht.
Der Staat tritt aber nun auf.
Aber es gibt zugleich keine Verknüpfung bei der CDU mehr mit so einem größeren
konservativen Programm.
Es gibt nur, jeder soll machen, was er will. Und wer Laila singen mag, mag Laila singen.
Und dies, glaube ich, ist nur noch in einem Punkt, und das ist das,
was Biebricher dann antwortet, dieses, wir müssen jetzt auch hier den heutigen
etwas aufbürden, wenn es um die Schuldenbremse geht.
Da sagt man nämlich, wir müssen hier Verzicht üben für die künftige Generation.
Das ist wichtig, das schützt uns alle. uns alle und schützt vor allem die Kinder
der Kinder. Und diese Schwundstufe dieser geistig-moralischen Wende ist die Schuldenbremse.
Aber versuchen wir nochmal auf diesen Punkt auszugehen, naja,
wenn die Austeritätspolitik eigentlich nur noch geblieben ist,
aber sonst will man eigentlich die Leute machen lassen.
Schneider-Jan fragt jetzt noch eine zweite Frage.
Aber ist das dann auch der Grund, dass sozusagen kulturell man den Leuten nichts mehr zumuten möchte,
dass da, wo es in diese etwas billigen Fragen geht,
sage ich jetzt mal, was darf man singen, was darf man essen,
da möchte man den Leuten nicht zumuten,
weil man ihnen vielleicht durch diese Austeritätspolitik, wie sie jetzt beschrieben
haben, durch die Schuldenbremse, durch die fehlenden Investitionen,
da ist schon genug zumutet und deswegen sagt man, dann lassen wir euch wenigstens
hier in Ruhe und das ist unser Angebot an euch?
Aber es wird ja wenig zugemutet, also auf anderem Gebiet.
Also klar, man hat diese normativen Grenzen, dass man dann dieses Gürtel enger
schnallen Ding, aber das ist ja auch aus der Kohl-Zeit.
Ich habe das auch noch so als Gefühlerinnerung, dass alle so auf diese Frage,
na wie geht's? Na ja, man muss ja irgendwie und so. Und im Fernsehen hieß es
dann immer Gürtel enger schnallen. Also es war diese Sabine-Christiansen-Jahre.
Aber man mutet den Leuten doch sehr viel zu. Wir haben natürlich jetzt nicht
eine grüne Politik im Sinne von Heizung oder irgendwelche Sachen werden verboten.
Aber wenn man sich jetzt ansieht, wie die Reallöhne sinken,
wenn man sich ansieht, wie teuer es ist,
zu wohnen oder zu bauen, wenn man sich ansieht,
wie prekär die Zukunft eigentlich aussieht, auch nicht nur auf den Klimawandel,
sondern auch sicherheitspolitisch und so weiter gesehen, dann kann man sagen,
sind die Leute vielleicht sogar an dem Punkt, wo sie.
Unpolitisch denken in dem Sinne, dass sie sagen, ich glaube eh nicht mehr,
dass sich da was verbessert.
Also dass man sagt, ich glaube nicht, dass mein Lohn noch so steigen wird,
dass ich mir ein Haus leisten kann.
Ich glaube nicht daran, dass wir nochmal eine bessere Gesundheitsversorgung
in den Krankenhäusern kriegen.
Ich glaube nicht daran, dass meine Kinder in ordentliche Schulen kommen.
Aber eines möchte ich wenigstens mir noch behalten, das ist zu sagen, was ich will.
Und das ist, glaube ich, ein Punkt, den man nicht unterschätzen sollte,
dass diese, man kann das auch kleinbürgerlichen Trotz oder was nennen,
dass diese Reaktion eigentlich sehr logisch ist von Leuten, die eigentlich die
Politik abgeschrieben haben, sagen, ich glaube jetzt eh nicht mehr,
dass sich da etwas Relevantes verbessert, aber ich will wenigstens noch das und das sagen können.
Und damit behalte ich meine Restwürde und das konnten wir in Amerika auch bei den Trump Wählern,
die im Trailerpark wohnten und was weiß ich sehen, die sagten ja,
aber klar, ich kann mir noch nicht mal meine Medikamente gegen die Diabetes
leisten, aber ich will noch das und das sagen können.
Und dieser Punkt scheint mir sehr entscheidend zu sein, dass man erkennt,
dass es also da etwas gibt, was man tatsächlich heute würde man sagen, triggern kann.
Ja, die Übung, die die Politik und damit meine ich jetzt alle Parteien so ein
bisschen drin sieht, ist ja das Zuschreibungsspiel zu machen. Also Blame Game.
Latent argumentieren. Also wir würden es nie deutlich sagen,
aber man sieht das ja so bei Lars Klingbeil oder besonders bei Christian Dürr,
der ja dann immer so mit diesem, ja dieses ganze Chaos und so weiter.
Ich verstehe ja, dass Robert Habe ganz aufgeregt ist, ne?
Und da steckt ja drin dieses, liebe Bürger, euch wird von der Realität so viel abverlangt.
Die Inflation hat ja nichts mit uns zu tun, sondern mit dem brutalen Angriffskrieg
von Wladimir Putin und so weiter. Und dann wird das alles so durchargumentiert.
Und dann wird so halb explizit gesagt,
ohne dass man es ihnen jetzt direkt vorwerfen kann, dass dann der Olaf Scholz
dasteht und mit Schweigen uns vermittelt, wir wissen, die Realität setzt euch
ganz schön zu, wir belästigen euch jetzt nicht auch noch mit Politik.
Und darüber wird dann die ganze Zeit die grüne Partei so zurück gepfiffen,
obwohl die die einzigen sind, die jetzt gerade noch so einen Gestaltungsspielraum
irgendwie definieren und darin dann halt ihre Suchbewegung machen.
Aber alle von außen, also von der CDU inklusive der schweigenden SPD bis dann
zur AfD, sagen dann, das sind diese Grünen.
Und dann kommt Merz und sagt, also diese Grünen sorgen für diese Panik und so
weiter. Nimmt komplett dieses FDP-Leitbild von Christian Dürr,
übernimmt das einfach. Ja, der Habeck, der bringt ja alles. Das ist eh schon
Chaos. Sieht er das denn nicht? Und jetzt will der auch noch und so.
Und das ist so tragisch, weil wir ja derzeit… Richtet sich auch nur gegen Habeck,
also Baerbock ist ja zum Beispiel ganz raus, weil Baerbock ja den NATO-Kurs
vertritt, deswegen ist sie ja Everybody's Darling, sogar in der Bild-Zeitung.
Da kann man nichts offenbar angreifen, also verschweigt man sie lieber,
spielt ja gar keine Rolle irgendwie.
Habeck wird dann angegriffen und sehr tragisch ist ja die Nachrichtenlage,
dass wir eine erfolgreiche Notentscheidung angestrebt von,
der CDU haben, Sachstand. Das, was derzeit abläuft, ist nicht normal.
Das kann man auch nicht erklären. Also da muss jetzt niemand irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, das ist alles so ein Chaos, ich blick da nicht mehr durch.
Ja, da blickt man nicht mehr durch. Das lässt sich alles nur noch,
keine Ahnung, vielleicht kann man noch so heuristisch irgendwie spieltheoretische
Aufstellungen oder sowas da einmal durchgehen.
Ich würde sagen man kann es wie die die klatschpresse rezipieren
also ich habe es gibt hat irgendwelche streitereien
also die bild zeitung hat ja zum einen diese
ampel streitigkeiten den ganzen tag online bespielt
das oder irgendetwas aus dem reich der b prominenten spielerfrau a zieht bei
fußballer b aus und ist jetzt mit spielerfrau c zusammen diese ganzen dinge
gestern habe ich gelesen multimillionär aus hamburg will seine villa verkaufen
mit patrizia planko drin.
Das ist auch eine schöne Idee. Ja, so Sachen liest man dann den ganzen Tag.
Man versteht das auch nicht. Es hat irgendwas zu tun. Die haben noch mal miteinander
diskutiert. Können wir nochmal eine Schlagzeile machen? Ja, dann sag irgendwas
Verrücktes. Nadel hat keine Zeit. Dann kommt sie morgen.
Und so funktioniert das eigentlich da an der Berichterstattung.
RTL exklusiv, aber nicht mit den schönen und reichen, sondern mit den mächtigen.
Und dann geht man das einmal so punktuell durch.
Auf der anderen Seite, nachdem ich das gestern auch mal so twitterte,
dass das wirklich gerade nicht normal ist, was da abläuft, schrieb mir dann gleich Fabian,
der ja schon ein paar mal im Fernsehpodcast zu Gast war, ja wir können dann,
wenn das Gesetzespaket Klima so weit durch ist und das GEG ist ja auch nur ein
Teil davon, gerne mal im Podcast drüber reden, weil so schlecht ist das ja alles
gar nicht. Und da habe ich so gedacht, ja das stimmt wahrscheinlich.
So schlecht ist wahrscheinlich nicht, was da irgendwie 300 engagierte Parlamentarier
und 3000 Leute in den Ministerien gerade erarbeiten. Aber es dringt nirgendwo mehr durch.
Es wird so von außen formal zerhackstückelt, dass dann irgendwie das Verfassungsgericht
Notbremsen einlegt und man kommt halt zu nichts.
Aber die inhaltliche Arbeit ist ja dann irgendwie komplett verschenkt.
Sie findet statt, aber ist dann
irgendwie verschenkt. Also es ist wirklich ganz irre, was wir da sehen.
Und nun wollen wir zu des Wesens Kern kommen mit Rezo. Du hast uns da was mitgebracht.
Er war ja auch auf der OMR.
Und man fragt sich immer, wie taxiert man den Wert von z.B. Influencern?
Was, also wir wissen alle, was eine Milch kostet, selbst ein Politiker wie Olaf
Scholz würde sich das nicht mehr nehmen lassen, vor einem Sommerinterview nachzufragen,
was kostet eigentlich gerade ein Liter Milch und dann würde er sagen 1,69 Euro oder so.
Würden die sagen, nein, das ist schon wieder nur 1,29 Euro.
Also was kostet was? Und auf dieser,
wir hatten ja Jeremy Fragrance geguckt, Rezo hat auch ein Video zu Jeremy Fragrance
gemacht und hat dort heute so, hat dort so ganz nebenbei irgendwie,
als er so aus seinem Chat gefragt wurde und wie viel Geld hast du so?
Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, es ist schon so siebenstellig, aber ich weiß nicht
so genau, ich habe mich lange nicht mehr auf meinen Konten eingeloggt und so.
Also diesen Clip kann man sich bei YouTube anschauen.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie viel Geld ich überhaupt habe, mehr kennst du nicht.
Genau, kommt ja so bei einigen die Frage auf, wie kommt man ins so Geld siebenstellig,
so ungefähr zwischen 1.000.000 und 9.999.000 und so weiter.
Und Rezo hat auf der OMR-Bühne erklärt, wie er Geld verdient.
Und ich fand es irgendwie sehr illustre, denn wir haben ja diese Veranstaltung
schon besprochen, als sie weiß selber nicht so genau, was sie ist.
Sie ist im Grunde zu groß.
Auch die Macher wissen nicht mehr genau, was müssen wir denen jetzt genau bieten.
Und dann versuchen sie halt über so einen Ticketpreis 400 Euro für alle,
es gibt dann gar keine großen Klassifizierungen, so ein Angebot zu schaffen,
wo jeder irgendwie seiner Personalabteilung sagen kann, da muss dich jetzt hin.
400 Euro liegt ja weit unter der Schwelle, dass wir das genehmigen lassen müssen.
Also hier, tschau, viel Spaß. Kannst ja einfach hinfahren.
Und dadurch sammeln sich da extrem viele Leute in Hamburg, gehen zu diesem OMR-Festival.
Und der eine oder andere versucht dann noch, die schnelle Markt zu machen, unter anderem Rezo.
Und er stellt uns hier sein Business vor. Ich fand es wirklich grandios interessant,
sag ich mal so. Und ich glaube, es gibt da aber noch einiges zu,
wie nennt man es, dekonstruieren oder mal so.
Nindo ist ja sein Unternehmen.
Genau, Nindo heißt sein Unternehmen. Das kennen wir ja schon.
Das macht diese Social Media Analyse.
Ratings.
Ratings, genau. Speichert so alles mal weg. Und er beginnt mit einer Fachwort Olympiade natürlich.
Ich war letztes Jahr schon hier. Hab einen Vortrag hier auf der Stage gehalten.
Hab auch Masterclasses gemacht über so ein ganz nischiges Thema.
Ich habe über Botting gesprochen, wie Leute am Botten sind auf Social Media
und bin da ganz nischig reingegangen und im Nachgang habe ich mich mit ganz
vielen Leuten aus der Influencer-Marketing-Szene unterhalten und die fanden
das auch spannend und so.
Aber in den Gesprächen habe ich immer wieder dieselben Sachen festgestellt.
Ich habe immer wieder gemerkt, dass die Leute, mit denen ich spreche,
die eigentlich ja Profis sein sollten, manche sehr basic Sachen von Social Media
nicht verstehen oder die Auswirkungen von sehr basic Sachen auf Social Media nicht checken.
Heute möchte ich deswegen über Non-Persistenz auf Social Media sprechen.
Klingt jetzt erstmal fucking nerdy. Ja, ich weiß.
So, Non-Persistenz und Botting.
Also Bots, das kann man sich jetzt noch vorstellen, was das ist.
Persistenz, wir wissen ja was Persistenz ist. Etwas ist persistent da oder eben nicht.
Und Non-Persistenz bezogen auf die sozialen Medien bedeutet dann?
Storys zum Beispiel, die nur 24 Stunden halten, Chats die sich wieder löschen oder was auch immer.
Das Modell was er hier fährt ist ja angelehnt, er macht ja im Grunde,
ist ja der neue Sascha Lobo.
Es ist dieses Haar-Marketing, Frisuren-Marketing, nennt Sascha Lobo das.
Und er hat sich noch was Zweites abgeguckt bei Sascha Lobo, nämlich die subtile
Publikumsbeschimpfung.
Sodass man sich so ein bisschen schlecht fühlt, dass man noch nicht so ganz so up to date ist.
Genau. Man steht auf der Bühne und sagt, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen nerdy
und zeigt damit, dass man sich traut, ein Urteil über das eigene Publikum zu
fällen, nämlich, dass es nicht ganz so auf der Höhe ist wie man selbst.
Also non-persistente Social Media Anwendungen werden ja die Leute,
die da sitzen, vermutlich kennen und von Bots haben ja alle schon gehört.
Das ist ja schon mal die Frage, was adressiert er da eigentlich für ein Publikum?
Genau, man denkt ja, da sitzen Fachleute. Ich würde sagen, da sitzen auch Leute,
die das halt beruflich machen. Die wissen, dass eine Story nach 24 Stunden verschwindet.
Und ich denke mir ja irgendwie, Non-Persistenz ist jetzt nicht irgendwie der
Sonderfall, die Ausnahme oder was auch immer, sondern das ist der Standard.
Social Media ist nun mal nach Doom-Scrolling ausgelegt. Man scrollt unendlich
lange und die Tweets, die man mal gesehen hat und wieder suchen möchte, findet man nie.
Also es ist nichts Persistent im Social Media, es sei denn, man hat es sich
irgendwie weggespeichert als Bookmark oder sonst irgendwie. Also in der Hinsicht
finde ich das schon mal interessant, dass er hier so ein Programm aufmachen
möchte, von dem ich sage, nee, das ist eigentlich der Standardfall.
Es wäre total überraschend, wenn er jetzt da stünde und einen Vortrag hielte
zum Thema, kennt ihr alle dieses Phänomen, ihr seht da so ein lustiges Video,
Pinguine springen ins Wasser und der eine macht dabei einen Looping und drei
Tage später möchtet ihr das eurer Nichte zeigen und ihr findet es aber nicht wieder.
Ich habe die Lösung dafür, also sozusagen Persistenz herzustellen,
nicht Non-Persistenz, sondern Persistenz zum Thema machen.
Da würde ich sagen, das wäre ein Megathema, wenn einem das sozusagen,
wir nähern uns ja so langsam mit AI und so, dass man wirklich den Suchbegriff eingibt.
Und wir haben es ja auf der Bühne besprochen, du hast dich auch darüber gewundert,
jetzt werden auch Haustiere auf den Fotos erkannt. Man kann das Haustier als
Begriff suchen und Apple findet dann die Fotos entsprechend.
Das ist ja sozusagen die eigentliche Herausforderung, Persistenz herzustellen,
wo eigentlich alles voller Non-Persistenz ist. Man macht ein Foto,
man sieht ein Tweet und findet es schon drei Stunden später nicht mehr wieder.
Deswegen mache ich ständig Screenshots, füge die in Dateien ein,
damit ich im Podcast nochmal drüber reden kann.
Ja, oder beim Podcast hören. Man macht sich ein Screenshot von der Zeitmarke,
weil ich habe heute Mittag irgendwo irgendwas gehört.
So, finde das mal wieder in den acht Stunden Podcast, die du gehört hast.
Also Non-Persistenz ist eigentlich, würde ich sagen, der Standardfall des Internets.
Aber er möchte jetzt Non-Persistenz als Idee hier nochmal vermacken.
Gut. Er möchte aufklären diesen, hat man ja gehört eben, das ist so dieses,
was Sascha Lobo ja auch macht.
Er hat ja bei der Republika immer die Lage zur Nation oder so was gehalten,
diese Rede, wo er dann auch immer erst mal das Publikum beschimpfte im Sinne
von ihr engagiert euch nicht richtig, macht's doch mal wie und dann kommen solche
Sachen wie die Vogelschützer in Bayern, die es hinbekommen, ganze Windparks
zu zerstören, nur weil sie so ein Vogel schützen wollen.
Und genau so müssten wir eigentlich das Internet schützen.
Engagiert euch doch mal. Also so mit dieser Art von ...
Ich beschimpfe euch und bringe euch damit in Wallung, aber überrasche ich euch
dann auch im nächsten Moment mit irgendwelchen Sachen, wo ihr denkt,
naja, stimmt, du hast ja doch irgendwie recht und so. Naja. Er möchte aufklären.
Wie gezielt Influencer diese Eigenschaft ausnutzen, das werde ich gleich zeigen,
um ein bisschen rumzutricksen, um ein bisschen zu flunkern, um ein bisschen
mehr Geld rauszuhandeln, als sie eigentlich kriegen sollten, für Placements oder so.
Aber ich werde auch zeigen, dass man das alles lösen kann, Indem man datengetriebenes
Influencer-Marketing macht, also indem man sozusagen viele Daten hat und darauf aufbauen kann.
Aber erstmal ganz kurz zu mir, vielleicht denkt sich der eine oder andere jetzt
von euch so, ey, das ist doch dieser YouTuber.
Und das bin ich, ich bin doch dieser YouTuber.
Es geht jetzt darum zu zeigen, dass klappern zum Handwerk gehört im Influencer-Business.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig verspannt habe.
Ja, Grieso ist was ganz Heißem auf der Spur.
Im Aufmerksamkeitsspiel gibt es verschiedene Tricks, die er uns jetzt zeigen kann.
Was keiner wusste bisher, dass man sich da irgendwie falsche Federn ansteckt
oder vielleicht besonders laut agiert, obwohl man so gar nichts zu sagen hat.
Also lauter solche Sachen. Das ist ganz verrückt. ganz verrückt,
wir können ja gleich nochmal ein Wort verlieren über, wir haben ja auch keine
Einblicke, aber wie war das eigentlich damals im Fernsehzeitalter und so,
als man sagte, okay, ich bin jetzt irgendwie Valensiner und ich möchte jetzt meinen Saft bewerben.
An welcher Kennziffer hat man eigentlich, welche wirtschaftliche Entscheidung
zum Thema, wo platzieren wir die Werbung, wie sieht die Werbung aus und überhaupt gemacht?
Das war alles ins Blaue hinein, in den Nebel, man hatte keine Ahnung von nichts.
Ja, wer schaut im Fernsehen? Ja, keine Ahnung, sehr viele Leute.
Die gesellschaftliche Konsumforschung hat gesagt, so und so viele,
ja, dann glauben wir das mal und so.
Ja, und diese werberelevante Zielgruppe, aber wir sind ja gar nicht in dieser
Zielgruppe drin mit unserem Produkt, diese ganzen Fragen. Oder auch die Sendung,
passt die moralisch zu unserem Produkt? Das war ein ganz sehr fairer,
älterer Problem, Werbepartner für das Dschungelcamp zu finden.
Bis sie dann merken, ach nee, die ganzen Familien sitzen da vor und gucken das,
dann können wir auch unsere üblichen Supermarktprodukte dort bewerben.
Genau, lauter solche Fragen. Und dann kam ja das Internet, und zwar nicht gestern
oder so, sondern, sagen wir mal, Spiegel Online 1994.
Die große, seriös angetriebene Werbewelle, die dann einmal durchrauscht,
den ganzen Journalismus mit sich riss, wie wir heute wissen, in den Untergang.
Und seitdem war ja klar, wir haben Chartbeat, wir können einfach jede Sekunde
jeden Nutzer nachvollziehen, was macht er eigentlich gerade,
wo ist seine Maus, was klickt er an, was interessiert ihn.
Also gar nichts mehr ins Blaue hinein. Dann kam Social Media,
wir hatten diese Followerzahlen, wir haben genau gesehen, wer wie viele Tweets,
wir haben jetzt irgendwie Elon Musk gesagt, ich zeige euch nur 600 Tweets.
Und auch 600 Tweets ist aber auch wirklich Schluss, weil man kann ja alles mitzählen,
also wer liest, wird gelesen, galt seitdem, wie Shomara da immer sagte.
Und man fragt sich so, und das reicht jetzt noch nicht, also Rezo muss da jetzt
noch eine Schippe drauflegen,
auf diesen ganzen Zahlensalat, der in das ohnehin schon super erfolgreiche Medien-
und Werbebusiness bis dahin kam, denkt er jetzt, ich muss da noch,
da müssen noch andere Zahlen drauf, das reicht doch nicht.
Ja, vieles sehr transparentes über Rabattcodes, Affiliate Links und dergleichen,
das heißt, da sehen ja Leute direkt, wie wirksam eine Werbung ist bei einem Influencer.
Ja, es gibt eigentlich keine Lücke mehr, würde ich sagen.
Aber da ist es dann ziemlich klar, gut, wenn man jetzt beispielsweise Julien
Bam für Fanta oder sowas werben lässt, dann hat das eine große Streuwirkung,
ob das dann am Ende sich gerechnet hat für das Produkt, wer kann das so genau sagen?
Die Marke ist auch so präsent im Kopf,
ist sie dann noch mal präsenter da, wer weiß es schon, also manches muss ja
auch dauernd penetriert werden,
damit es im Käufergehirn präsent ist, man kann das eigentlich so halb abschätzen,
aber ich glaube, des Pudels Kern kann man nicht gelangen, weil es vielleicht keinen gibt.
Ja, man macht den Vorgang auf und es ist genau nichts hinter der Bühne so.
Was ist der Fall und was steckt dahinter? Und Lumans Antwort war nichts nach
30 Jahren Forschung zur Soziologie.
Naja, also wir haben dieses, diese große neue Idee von RISO,
wir könnten ja in einem Werbeumfeld, das schon Überwachungskapitalismus gelabelt
wird, noch mehr Daten sammeln.
Aber eigentlich habe ich meinen Master in Informatik gemacht,
habe meine Masterarbeit über sich verändernde Netzwerke,
also das, was die sozialen Netzwerke auch sind,
geschrieben und habe dann ein Unternehmen gegründet,
Nindo heißt es, und da sammeln wir Milliarden von Daten aus verschiedenen sozialen Netzwerken,
um eben mit verschiedenen Analysen und Tools dann im Influencer-Marketing Brands
und die Agenturen zu unterstützen.
So, er sammelt Milliarden von Daten. Bei solchen Floskeln werde ich immer schon
stutzig, weil das ist wie damals, als die NSA-Sachen aufgedeckt wurden und...
Die deutschen Journalisten so ein bisschen uneins darüber waren,
wie geht man jetzt mit diesen Snowden-Enthüllungen um?
Und dann hat man gesagt, ja, das ist ganz wichtig, weil das ganz viel ist,
es betrifft so viel. Und dann hat man immer geschrieben, ja,
in diesem Dokument zeigt Snowden, wie die NSA Milliarden von Daten sammelt.
Und alle so, Milliarden von Daten? Wie ist das jetzt gemeint?
Sind jetzt Daten, also Daten, es ist so verschiedene Datums oder was?
Und es war dann einfach nur so Datenpunkte irgendwie, aber keiner hatte,
also der Maßstab war völlig irre.
Und man muss jetzt auch bei Rezo fragen, also er sammelt Milliarden von Daten,
aber nicht Billionen von Daten. Das wäre irgendwie cooler, Billionen zu haben.
Wenn Milliarden schon gut ist, ist ja Billionen eigentlich cooler.
Woher weiß man, dass er nicht Billionen sammelt? Also es ist irgendwie so völlig
komisch, das so zu sagen. Aber was macht man mit diesen Milliarden von Daten?
Man speichert weg, was non-persistent ist.
Er erklärt jetzt also seinen Kunden, die da potenziellen Kunden,
die vor ihm sitzen, sein Anliegen.
Wenn ich jetzt eine Influencerin habe und ich sehe den Channel und ich frage
mich als Brand, will ich die buchen?
Dann habe ich ja vielleicht so Fragen wie, ja hat die vielleicht für einen Mitbewerber
schon mal Werbung gemacht?
Kann ich nicht beantworten, weil die Storys, wo sie vielleicht Werbung gemacht hat, sind ja weg.
Oder wenn ich mir die Frage stelle, wie viel Werbung hat sie denn im letzten
Monat oder in der letzten Zeit so gemacht? Ich will ja nicht Werbung sozusagen
bei ihr buchen, wenn sie jeden Tag für eine andere Brand wirbt.
Das kann ich auch nicht beantworten, weil die Storys eben weg sind.
Und selbst wenn ich mich dann dafür entscheide und sage, ja,
okay, ich buche dich, mach ein Placement.
Du machst am Wochenende ein Placement für meine Brand und du darfst aber am
selben Tag oder am Tag davor Tag danach, nicht für wen anders noch Werbung machen.
Das ist eine ganz typische Klausel, die in so Verträgen drin sind.
Dann macht die am Wochenende ganz, ganz viele Storys. Ich komme am Montag ins
Office rein und ich sehe die ja gar nicht mehr. Ich kann gar nicht nachvollziehen,
hat sie sich daran gehalten.
So, früher war das so, man buchte Plakatwerbung und dann buchte man einfach,
man hängt an 750 Plakaten im Raum Rhein-Main an Bushaltestellen.
Wie hat man das überprüft? Und das kostet ja irgendwie 10 Euro am Tag pro Plakat,
also man bezahlt irgendwie 7000 Euro und dann hängt man da so eine Woche und
dann kostet es jeden Tag 7000 Euro. Euro. Man bezahlt dann 50.000 Euro.
Und wie überprüft man eigentlich, dass man die 50.000 gut angelegt hat,
dass wirklich an 750 Haltestellen das Plakat liegt?
Naja, man schickt halt jemanden los, der mal so stichprobenartig sich drei,
vier Plakate anschaut und sagt, ja, die hängen da, die anderen hängen wahrscheinlich
auch. Mehr Sicherheit hatte man nicht.
Im Fernsehen. Ja, man bucht halt, keine Ahnung, so im RTL irgendwas,
Superfilm, da kommt Jurassic Park 1993 im Fernsehen oder so.
Und dann bucht man halt so Werbung und hofft, dass es einfach viele sehen.
Hatte man irgendwelche Anhaltspunkte?
Ja, die GfK hat irgendwie gesagt, das haben so und so viele Leute gesehen. Mehr hatte man nicht.
Alles, was man irgendwie absichern wollte, ich zeig aber wirklich den Spawn,
der kommt an dritter Stelle und so weiter, wurde halt vertraglich gesichert.
Wie auch jetzt die angesprochene Influencerin vermutlich sich an den Vertrag
halten würde, denn das Risiko ist ja hoch, wenn sie das ja öffentlich postet,
dass es dann ausgerechnet jemand aus der Firma sieht, doch da kam gar keine Werbung.
Das ist doch irre, dass man sich jetzt hier ganz, wie soll man sagen,
es schleicht sich so ein, seid mal missgünstig.
Wenn ihr das vertraglich regelt, dass dieser und jener am Samstag eure Werbestory
bringt, aber am Sonntag dann keine, dann müsst ihr das überprüfen.
Ohne Überprüfung unsererseits wäre das nicht zu machen und da kann man ja schon mal sich fragen,
naja aber wenn man sich jetzt fragt, okay wir wollen die jetzt buchen und wir
fragen die dann, hast du denn innerhalb der letzten fünf Wochen für den Mitbewerber
geworben und die sagt dann nein, dann glaubt man das nicht?
Selbst wenn man sich von ihr unterschreiben lässt.
Das ist ja auch bei Buchverträgen, also wenn du jetzt einen Buchvertrag machst,
dein nächstes Projekt soll ja Familie werden,
dann kannst du natürlich einen Buchvertrag irgendwann unterschreiben und da
wird sicherlich irgendwas drinstehen,
dass du nicht zu diesem Thema noch in einem anderen Verlag in den nächsten zwei
Jahren ein Buch schreibst, weil du dann natürlich den Konkurrenz machen würdest.
So oder die und die zweimal Vorschuss bezahlt haben, ob du das dann doch machst.
Das werden die erst dann herausfinden, wenn es präsent ist oder was weiß ich,
aber dann wirst du ja abgemahnt dafür. Also das heißt.
Ja genau.
Ich würde sagen, alles was Influencer machen ist ja so publik.
Ja das ist ja eigentlich das Ziel davon.
Und ja, jetzt kann ich sagen, ich kann jetzt mal nachvollziehen,
was hat die vor drei Monaten gemacht und hat die für irgendwas dubioses geworben,
aber ich sag mal, das ist ja inzwischen auch ein Influencer Business geworden,
das mit großen Agenturen zusammenarbeitet, die auch auf eine gewisse Seriosität Wert legen.
Klar, wenn wir jetzt hier über Influencer reden, die irgendwelche Adapter verkaufen,
mit denen man angeblich via Smartphone die Zähne bleachen kann,
dann sind wir sowieso im Milieu angekommen irgendwo.
Aber bei den anderen Sachen würde ich sagen, ist das eine ziemlich sichere Bank
und ich weiß aber auch natürlich, dass im Marketing, wie überall versucht wird,
der höchste Preis rauszuholen.
Und wir hatten ja immer solche Geschichten auch gehabt von irgendwelchen Werbeagenturen,
die so ein Stadtlogo entworfen haben. Dann hat das 80.000 Euro gekostet und
war am Ende aber nur ein Smiley. Und man hat sich gefragt, ach so.
Und was haben die da gemacht? Naja, dann schreiben die auf. Wir hatten 47 Brainstorming-Sitzungen.
Das weiß man nicht. Das weiß man aber auch ganz oft bei künstlerischen Leistungen
nicht. Wenn man angefragt wird für einen Vortrag. Ja, Vorbereitungszeit.
Irgendwas weiß ich nicht. Kann man ja alles sich ausdenken.
Genau, ich würde auch sagen, wenn ihr Wert darauf legt, dass das richtig beworben wird,
dann kümmert euch um die Story, um die es dann geht, wo euer Name drin ist und
lasst euch einfach vorher zusichern, dass nicht die fünf Monate vorher irgendwie
ein Konkurrent beworben wurde und wenn das dann vertraglich da steht, steht das da.
Ob man das dann nochmal mit Zahlen absichern muss, also da steckt so ein gewisses
Misstrauen dem System gegenüber drin.
Und als zweiten Punkt hatte das Faken von Followerzahlen.
Wie könnte ich als Influencer dieses Toolkit, das ich habe, das ich nachträglich
Dinge verändern kann, nutzen, um meinen Werbepartnern vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr Geld aus der Tasche zu ziehen, als ich eigentlich kriegen sollte.
Zum Beispiel durch Gewinnspiele. Gewinnspiele sind eine wahnsinnig gute Art,
der Community was zurückzugeben, klar, aber Gewinnspiele boosten auch die Follower
und die Likes und die Kommentare und so weiter.
Also wir erfahren jetzt, dass man dafür sorgen kann durch Gewinnspiele,
dass man mehr Interaktionen hat und dies zeigt dann potenziellen Kunden.
Seht her, ist besonders erfolgreich in den sozialen Medien, deswegen ist der
TKP, also der tausender Kontaktpreis 15 Euro höher.
Aber in Wahrheit resultiert diese hohe Interaktion aus Gewinnspielen,
die veranstaltet wurden.
Da frage ich mich aber, wo ist der Unterschied? Ich kann generell sagen,
er hat eine hohe Reichweite, weil er sich oft nackt zeigt oder halb nackt zeigt.
Da kann ich mich auch fragen. Wir wissen ja, dass Leute sehr stark von ihren
Begierden getrieben werden in den sozialen Medien, das meint auch die sexuellen
Begierden. Auch die sexuellen Begierden.
Da weiß man, dass nackte Haut vom Algorithmus präferiert wird und von den Leuten, die da sind.
Kann ich darüber nachdenken, wenn ich ein Produkt bewerbe, muss da noch blank
gezogen werden seitens der Influencer?
Oder wie machen wir es, dass es eine hohe Reichweite hat, dass es viel gesehen
wird? Und dann ist immer noch die Frage, haben die Leute währenddessen auf das Produkt geguckt Genau.
Ich meine, was ist ein Gewinnspiel? Gewinnspiel ist ja nur ein Social Media
Inhalt, der halt noch angefüttert ist mit, wenn ihr das macht,
dann passiert das und das. Also wenn ihr mir hier noch extra Follower und so
weiter. Ob das Essen so gewü...
Gelingt, ist ja die eine Frage. Es geht ja gerade so eine große Mr.
Beast Thematisierung durch. Die New York Times hat jetzt The Daily dazu gemacht,
in Hard Fork haben sie darüber gesprochen und Mr.
Beast hat ja so eine Sache durchschaut, nämlich, dass die Leute so eine Art
minimale Selbstwirksamkeit haben wollen.
Also wenn Mr. Beast ihnen verspricht, für jeden neuen Follower,
den ich die nächste Woche, Also jeden neuen Abonnenten, den ich auf YouTube
die nächste Woche habe, spende ich zehn Cent an so und so.
Dann sitzen alle da und sehen, ah, wenn ich jetzt, dann ist es einer mehr.
Dann sieht man so, am nächsten Morgen sind es schon eine Million mehr.
Und dann fragt er sich, das sind ja schon 100.000 Dollar.
Und dann kommt halt dieses Video eine Woche später, wo einfach,
keine Ahnung, 300.000 Dollar verschenkt werden. Bei drei Millionen neue Follower und so.
Und dieses Prinzip, ah ja, ich kann, wenn ich hier auf Followen klicke,
Ich bin ein echter Follower und ich interessiere mich auch wirklich dafür,
kommt dieses nächste Video und so weiter.
Also man ist ja dann eingefangen. Wenn man jetzt Rezos Misstrauen,
dass er hier streut, nämlich der Unterschied zwischen, ja, es gibt so echte
Follower und dann gibt es so Fake-Follower.
Da könnte man ja auch sich den Juno Naiv-Kanal anschauen. Der hatte damals 180.000
Follower. Und dann kam dieses Rezo-CDU-Video.
Und Rezo hat ja Thilo dann erwähnt, Weshalb von den 15 Millionen Views,
die auf Rezos Video abfielen, noch mal 180.000 auf Junge Naive Abonnenten entfielen.
Also dadurch, dass jemand, der ansonsten gar nichts mit Politik am Hut hat,
das allererste Mal überhaupt ein politisches Video macht, oder vielleicht vorher noch mal ein,
zwei politische, aber so mal ein richtig genuin politisches,
journalistisches Video, ist dann der Junge Naive-Account von 180 auf 360 Follower
innerhalb von einer Woche gesprungen. Würde man jetzt sagen, naja...
Lieber Bundeskanzler, wir wissen, dass der Thilo Jung gestern schon wieder den
Christian Lindner so gequält hat, aber von den 500.000 sind zumindest 180.000
nur keine echten Follower, weil die kamen nur über Rezo damals.
Das ist ja völlig absurd. Ja, ja.
Ich rufe jetzt auf, abonniert die Filmanalyse, aber bitte seid richtige Abonnenten.
Genau, bitte seid echt.
Also ihr müsst auch wirklich Filme so richtig mögen, nicht nur so Halbinteresse haben.
Ja, also diese Unterscheidung herbeizuargumentieren irgendwie,
als ob jetzt ein Content, der irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Aufmerksamkeit erregt
im Vergleich zu, ja da ist aber ein Gewinnspiel dabei. Also da müsste man jetzt
das Gewinnspiel nochmal einbetten.
Im Bereich des religiösen. Es gibt diesen schönen Begriff des Taufschein Katholiken.
Das sind Leute, die sind mal getauft, aber sonst ist denen der Katholizismus
egal. Und hier wird das so ein bisschen, als sei man dann noch nicht so,
man muss auch praktizieren da.
Ich würde sagen, wir sind hier mehr so eine Influencer-Kollektiv-Psychoanalyse,
in dem so die latenten Strukturen und das dahinterliegende, das mystische,
das ursprüngliche und so mal so thematisiert wird irgendwie.
Ja, das stimmt. Und da die ja immer in diesem Authentizitätskurs,
auf diesem Kurs sowieso segeln und jetzt muss es auch nicht nur authentische Influencer geben,
also die wirklich, wirklich dieses Produkt gut finden, sondern auch Follower,
die wirkliche Follower sind und nicht nur so.
Diese ganzen Plattformen, das haben wir in den 29ern aus allen Perspektiven bereits besprochen.
Diese ganzen Plattformen sind
so konstruiert, dass es möglichst wenige bewusste Entscheidungen gibt.
Denn da wo es bewusste Entscheidungen gibt, kann auch die Entscheidung nahe
liegen, ich gehe jetzt mal aus Instagram raus für heute. Also versucht man Leute
zu natschen in alle Richtungen.
So sind diese Plattformen aufgebaut, mithilfe von Psychologen entwickelt und
natürlich funktioniert das Business innerhalb dieser Plattformen auch genau
so, man kann da nicht zu einem Wesenskern gelangen.
Genau, man könnte höchstens, aber das ist so akademisches Beiwerk dann,
so für heuristische Zwecke, man könnte jetzt sagen, okay Riso,
du bist ja irgendwas auf der Spur, dann nehmen wir doch mal das Gewinnspiel
als eine Möglichkeit und finden noch 19 andere Klassen an, damit wird aber geboostet.
Und dann käme man, keine Ahnung, hier hat aber besonders viel Familiengeschichte
oder persönliche Betroffenheit gezeigt, das hätte dann ganz andere Leute abgeholt,
die wollten gar nichts kaufen, sondern die waren an ihm interessiert.
Dann könnte man sagen, ja, die sind jetzt besonders wertvolle Follower und so
weiter. Also man ist da so eine große, das finde ich auch gar nicht so uninteressant,
weil MrBeast zum Beispiel hat sich ja auch die Strategien genau angeschaut, was funktioniert.
Und seitdem kommt ja gar keine Story mehr in seinen Videos vor.
Am Anfang hat er immer noch Storys gehabt, jetzt kommt ja gar kein Narrativ mehr.
Das finde ich übrigens auch, das könnten wir mal im neuen Zwanziger ausführlicher
behandeln, weil jetzt immer alle, ja, das Narrativ ist ganz wichtig und der
rote Faden und das muss immer, keine Ahnung, das kennt man ja so in der Podcastwelle,
es muss so dieses durcherzählte Ding irgendwie sein, was auf ein Klimax zuläuft.
Dabei ist genau das Gegenteil wahr.
Dass er gar keine Story mehr bringt.
Ja, TickTock funktioniert ohne Story.
Genau, da hat man ja alle drei Sekunden irgendwas Neues oder alle 0,3 Sekunden.
Und bei MrBeast ist ja so, der verschenkt einfach 1.000 Operationen gegen Blindheit
und so weiter an irgendwelche Leute.
Und sammelt dann die Effekte ein und macht Videos daraus.
Genau, es geht nur noch um die Effekte. Es wird nur noch gezeigt,
hier, und auch er kann wieder sehen, und dann wird dieser Augenblick,
der ist, ah ja, ich kann sehen, und ihr seid dabei, wie ich's erst mal sehe.
Weil in Hardfork hat dann Casey Newton mal davon berichtet, dass er so einen
Text darüber las, wie es den Leuten, also wie die eigentlich dazu kam,
Teil dieses Videos zu sein.
Und da stellte sie so raus, ja das sind schon echt mega krasse Storys.
Also Leute, die seit Jahrzehnten sich das Geld zusammensparen,
um da irgendwie die eine Operation, die irgendwie dann ihren alten Onkel mal
wieder treffen, damit er den auch noch ein bisschen Geld gibt und dann kommt aber plötzlich...
Mr. Beast um die Ecke und verschenkt ihnen einfach diese Operation.
Und alle diese Storys, die wirklich ganze Leben beeinflussen,
enden dann damit, dass Mr. Beast es einfach bezahlt. Und damit diese Suche nach
dem Geld aufhört. Nur Mr. Beast greift keine von diesen tausend Storys auf.
Sondern die Storys sind ihm ganz egal, weil er genau weiß, die Leute interessiert
den Scheiß, diese Storys. Ich habe hier 165 Millionen Abonnenten auf YouTube,
die wollen Action sehen.
Die wollen einfach, wie bei Dieter Bohlen, der erste Ton kommt Und dann kommt
sofort der Szenenapplaus, da wird keine Story erzählt und so, ne?
Aber vielleicht zu Ihren Rätungen von Rezo und in Bezug auf MrBeast ist ja doch
eine Sache interessant,
nämlich, dass wir große digitale Reichweiten haben, die einen sehr geringen,
ich nenne es mal Realitätseffekt haben.
Das heißt, man sieht das mitunter bei sehr reichweitenstarken Leuten in Social
Medien, die eine Tournee machen und man denkt, die haben 250.000 Follower,
die werden ja wohl noch einen Saal mit 300 Leuten vollkriegen.
Und das ist dann nicht der Fall. Und dann denkt man sich, da wurde offenbar
algorithmisch alles richtig gemacht, da hat man vielleicht auch eine Show im
Öffentlich-Rechtlichen gehabt und da ging alles so nach oben.
Und es suggeriert natürlich für Außenstehende, sind wahnsinnig relevant,
aber nicht mal 300 Leute in Köln wollen ihn sehen.
Und Mr. Beast hat ja jetzt auch gerade doch eine solche Erfahrung.
Er hat diesen Mr. Beast-Burger vor einigen Monaten rausgebracht und stellt das nun ein.
Das heißt, die Idee war, er kann eigentlich über Monate, Jahre immer wieder
den Leuten Signale, Werbesignale senden. Ja, und jetzt vielleicht so einen Mr.
Beast-Burger mal probieren.
Aber das geht natürlich nur kurz. Es gibt diesen Hype, die.
Ausrede, warum es den jetzt nicht mehr gibt, ist natürlich, er konnte die hohen
Qualitätsstandards nicht einhalten und so weiter.
Aber man sieht dann, dass der Realitätseffekt oft nicht gegeben ist.
Und jetzt ist hier nochmal der Versuch mit so einem Tool einen stärkeren Realitätseffekt
herzustellen, also mit Leuten, die wirklich, wirklich wollen.
Genau, da bräuchte man eigentlich nochmal einen Begriff für in dem unterschaubaren
Chaos so eine neue Wirklichkeit zu etablieren,
die nochmal emergent so drüber liegt, die man sich dann nur, und das ist ja auch,
wir lesen nachher bei Evgeny Mohusov, das neue Versprechen der AI,
dass man da nochmal Approximationshoffnung zur Wirklichkeit hat,
die im Chaos ansonsten untergeht.
Also Rezo ist hier auf ganz heißer Spur, nämlich Gewinnspiele werden gepostet,
Follower werden eingesammelt mit dem Versprechen, wenn du hier drei Posts likest,
kommst du in den Gewinnspieltopf.
Und dann aber wieder gelöscht. Sodass man später den Anlass,
warum so viele, in Anführungszeichen, Fake-Follower da sind,
nicht mehr erkennt und darüber kann Nindo dann aufklären.
Von Carmen Geiss hab ich mir die letzten zehn Postings angeguckt,
bevor ich losgefahren bin hierhin.
Und von den letzten 10 Posts seht ihr jetzt hier zwei Balken.
Der linke Balken ist der echte Durchschnitt der Likes. Also wenn man sich alle
10 Postings, die sie zuletzt gepostet hat, anguckt, dann ist das der Durchschnitt der Likes.
Und man kommt bei ihr so fast auf 10.000 Likes pro Post auf diesem Balken?
Der rechte Balken ist das, was ihr glauben würdet, was der Durchschnitt ist,
wenn ihr auf ihr Profil guckt, denn Inhalte wurden gelöscht und zufällig halt
die Inhalte, vier Stück glaube ich, wurden gelöscht und zufällig die,
die halt nicht so gut liefen.
Wenn du natürlich von einer Menge die wenigen rausnimmst und dann den Durchschnitt
rechnest, dann steigt der Durchschnitt. Völlig klar.
Das ist ja exakt das, was Jeremy Frakens gesagt hat. Ich poste mehrere Sachen
am Tag und dann nehme ich das wieder runter, was nicht funktioniert.
Bei TikTok wird das ja auch empfohlen.
Na, so, also wir haben...
Sichtbar gefühlt 10.000 Likes pro Post, aber eigentlich sind es nur 7.000,
weil sie die Twinspiele, die das so triggern und so weiter, wieder rausnimmt
oder Unerfolgreiches löscht.
Also dann einfach so nach einer Woche Bilanz zieht und einfach nur von den sieben
Postings jeden Tag eine oder was weiß ich immer, dann drei stehen lässt für die Ewigkeit.
Und da denk ich mir so ein bisschen, ja, so läuft mein Twitter-Account ja auch.
Also das ist einfach die letzte Woche.
Und dann, wenn man jetzt so eine Nindo-Analyse macht, würde halt so und so viele
Likes, die ich eingesammelt habe, nur eine Woche Tweets gegenüberstehen.
Und dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich in so einer Rechnung auch meine Tausende Links
pro ... Und das geht dann halt alles nicht auf.
Sagt er. Da muss man dann genau hinschauen. Da wird man belogen.
Und jetzt kommt seine große Verkaufsansprache zum Schluss.
Ohne Nindo, also sein Social-Media-Scraping-Automat, der einfach im Hintergrund
alles wegspeichert, und dann auch behält und sogar noch mal vielleicht fleckt,
wenn dann Inhalte gelöscht sind.
Sodass man sich das Profil anschauen kann, aber die Lücken, die man ja heute
nicht mehr sieht, weil Posts gelöscht wurden, sind dann markiert mit.
Und hier war ein Gewinnspiel und da war ein markiertes Gewinnspiel,
dass man dann darüber mehr über den Account ...
Ist ein Archiv.
Im Grunde ist es ein Archiv, wie so ein Google-Index zu diesem Thema.
Wenn man mit Influencern Placements buchen möchte, man blind,
wenn man diese Tools nicht hat, dann fliegt man blind, wenn man einfach auf
die Kanäle drauf guckt und meint zu wissen, was die machen, was sie vielleicht
irgendwann mal gemacht haben. Da braucht man definitiv...
Ich werde über manche dieser Themen in meiner Masterclass noch sprechen.
Ich habe heute und morgen eine Masterclass.
Vielleicht sehe ich da den ein oder anderen von euch noch. Oder man sieht sich
am Nindo-Stand in Halle A2.
Das war es von meiner Seite aus. Ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Tag. Bis dann.
So, also Risa hat zum einen recht. Ja. In diesen Management-Entscheidungen,
wo platzieren wir unsere Werbung und so weiter, ist sehr viel Bauchentscheidung
und sehr viel Blindflug. Ja.
Aber das ist halt so. Und das war auch schon immer so. Und damit ist die Werbebranche auch gut gefahren.
Und man könnte auch überlegen, ob das eingepreist ist.
Ja genau, wir alle kennen ja diesen Spruch, dass irgendwer aus dieser Werbranche
sagt, ja mein Budget ist so und so hoch und eigentlich könnte ich mir die Hälfte
sparen, aber ich weiß nicht, welche Hälfte.
Ja.
Also muss ich halt alles investieren. Und so ist das halt in der Werbung. Ja. So und daran ändert.
Anzeigenmarkt in Zeitungen, kann man die schönsten Geschichten intern erzählen,
naja, was wird erzählt, welche, wie wichtig ist das noch eine Anzeige auf Seite
14 zu haben in der Zeitung.
Ja. Naja, kann man hier mal gucken, wie viel der Text darüber gelesen wird.
Es gibt ja solche Lesewerterhebungen und das sieht mitunter sehr mickrig aus,
wird aber was anderes erzählt.
Ich denke auch, man hat ja,
also es gibt ja nicht den TKP, wo man sagen kann,
also es ist ja nicht so, dass man beim Milchpreis, kann ich sagen,
der Milchpreis ist 1,69 Euro und der ist jetzt gerade so durchschnittlich Und
würde da im Supermarkt hier nebenan drei Euro kosten, würde man sagen,
nee, das entspricht immer nicht dem eigentlichen Milchpreis.
Aber beim TKP, ja, da wird man auch eine Relation herstellen können.
Aber was ich da schon alles gehört habe, was man zum Beispiel unter anderem
mit Podcastwerbung angeblich verdienen kann, da waren ja Summen dabei,
wo man dann dachte, ja, aber wer hat die je bekommen?
Also ich kenne einen Podcast, der mal 150 Euro TKP.
Und das ist ziemlich viel. Das sind also 15 Cent pro Hörer. Das ist wahnsinnig viel.
Gleichzeitig hast du dieses automatisiert, wird der Podcast einfach zerschnitten
und dann kommt so ein Werbeblock rein. Du hast damit gar nichts zu tun.
Dann kriegst du 10,50 Euro.
Dann so 2,50 Euro oder so. Also das ist wirklich grandios.
Ja, ja, ich meine, dann bekommst du oft, man kann das, es gibt ja so Tools,
wo man das so eingeben kann, also wo das dann automatisiert,
also wo man das noch nicht mal mehr selbst macht, wo die das dann anbieten.
Und da ist das dann mit einem Podcast mit 50.000 Reichweite,
hast du am Ende 20 Euro verdient. Also kann man sie lieber rauslassen.
Also da sind die TKPs so nicht der Rede wert. Also es schwankt so zwischen 2
Euro und 150 Euro und hängt also sehr viel davon ab.
Kannst du den Podcast selber gut verkaufen? Sprichst du diese Werbung selbst
in einem Podcast zum Beispiel?
Will dir auch jemand was Gutes tun? Also du hast ja meistens auch so Mäzen-Werbung,
die dann so stattfindet. Das ist gar nicht nur Produkt und Marketing.
Ist die Community kaufkräftig, ist das?
Genau, alles mögliche.
Also eigentlich könnte, ich hatte doch mal irgendwann vorgeschlagen,
man könnte den Podcast, den Wärmemarkt ja so austricksen.
Wir sagen irgendwann mal unserem Publikum, also passt auf, wir machen jetzt
künftig Werbung, das ist natürlich völliger Stuss, hört einfach nicht darauf,
aber wir fangen jetzt bald damit an.
Und das machen wir aber nonpersistent, damit das dann nicht mehr gefunden wird,
dass wir uns mal derart geäußert haben. Und dann fangen wir an für Diesel-Autos-Werbung
zu machen oder sonst was.
Aber alle, die uns hören, wissen, haha, die finden, das ist nicht deren Werbung
wirklich, sondern die verdienen jetzt so ihr Geld. Das wäre eigentlich ein tolles Modell.
Ja, also man könnte sich alles mögliche, also Non-Persistenz kann man überall einbauen,
also gerade auch beim Podcast ist es immer so, in einem Jahr gestreut man so die Signalworte,
auf die müsst ihr achten und danach wisst ihr, was wir die nächste Minute sagen,
also das ist wirklich Bullshit, aber wir kriegen halt Geld dafür und so und
dann lässt man das Signalwort und dann geht's los. Also so können wir noch Anti-Werbung machen.
Was halt Rezo hier macht, ist ja eine Werbebranche, die sowieso schon komplett
ins Zahlending abgetrifftet ist.
Was ihr auch nicht gut tut, weil wir sehen ja, wie die Werbung aussieht,
die wir bei Twitter, Instagram und so weiter bekommen.
Also im Vergleich zu, keine Ahnung, der tatsächlich inhaltlichen Aufklärung,
wie ein VW Käfer funktioniert von vor 50, 60 Jahren.
Im Fernsehen ist das ja wirklich, also wir haben es ja hier.
Ja auch nur Effekte werden gespielt.
Genau, bei diesen Target Dingen
und so, da wird einem ja wirklich nur Müll verkauft und überhaupt und so.
Und Rezos Angebot, was er hier macht, ist auf diesen ganzen Zahlensalat einfach
nochmal eine Schippe draufzulegen.
Also wir haben es hier nicht mit einer Verbesserung einer anderen emergenten
Stufe oder mit einem funktionalen Wandel oder irgendeiner konstruktiven Wende
oder so zu tun, sondern einfach nur Leute, die eh schon zahlengetrieben in die Irre geführt werden,
sage ich jetzt aus meiner Meinung als Werbekunde, der einfach Werbung sieht,
liegt da noch mal ein Zahlensalat oben drauf. Und das macht nichts besser.
Das suggeriert nur den Leuten, dass sie ihr Geld noch mal effektiver anlegen.
Nur das mit dem effektiven Anlegen war schon immer schwierig zu argumentieren
und wird hier auch nicht leichter zu argumentieren.
Also es ist wirklich ganz irre eigentlich.
Es bleibt neblig, das ist.
Absolut, das ist Fog of Advertising, was wir hier sehen.
Gut, wir gehen jetzt in den werbefreien Salon,
aus dem werbefreien Podcast hinaus, denn der ist ja auch werbefrei,
weil wir den Salon haben, wer also den Podcast unterstützen mag und sich vielleicht
auch noch für die Texte interessiert, die wir im Salon besprechen.
Und ja, wir stellen sie nicht nur kurz vor, sondern wir diskutieren sie zwei,
drei Stunden lang, kann den Salon abonnieren. Das ist möglich über Steady.
Das ist möglich über Spotify. Da kommt man dann zur Steady-Seite.
Das ist sehr einfach gemacht. Es ist auch möglich über Apple,
wenn man da schon Kunde ist, dann kann man den auch so buchen.
Und auch für diejenigen, die schon bei Patreon angemeldet sind,
ist es auch über Patreon möglich.
Allerdings präferieren wir da eher Steady.
So viel dazu. Wir haben sehr viel zu besprechen. Dieses dicke China Buch und
dann viele weitere Texte.
Und man kann übrigens noch nachhören, den Live Salon vom vergangenen Monat.
Dann sehen wir uns gleich im Salon.
Bis gleich.